you're looking at live pictures of
President Trump who is speaking right
now at a news conference in New Delhi at
the end of his two-day visit to India we
show Jang has been traveling with the
president there was a good morning
what's the president saying oh good
morning Tony in his first solo comments
here in India President Trump said he
wanted to avoid controversy and continue
celebrating a tremendous country that
likes us better than ever before he also
talked about Russian interference in the
twenty20 election saying he never got a
briefing that Bernie Sanders was the
favorite candidate that Russia was
trying to help even though the National
Security Advisor said on Face the Nation
that the FBI had told him that now in
joint remarks with Prime Minister Modi
this morning president Trump touted
progress on a trade deal but both
leaders declined to reveal any new
details mr. Trump was also met with
great fanfare at India's presidential
palace and stopped by the Raj Ghat
memorial to Indian Civil Rights icon
Mahatma Gandhi the president also spoke
about the deadly coronavirus declaring
that the u.s. is in very good shape and
that the stock market would get under
control after the Dow plummeted more
than a thousand points yesterday Anthony
Lee Shashank in New Delhi Thanks we
should